Reverend Robert Sirico has been active
in public policy for more than 20 years
his concern that religious communities
knew little about the economic issues
surrounding today's social problems
prompted him to found the Acton
Institute for the Study of religion and
liberty in 1990 father sirico regularly
lectures both in this country and around
the world and his writings have appeared
in various journals including The Wall
Street Journal the New York Times Forbes
National Review in the London Financial
Times you may have seen him recently on
Fox News and other television shows
discussing his latest book defending the
free market the moral case for a free
economy which was released just in May
of this year in addition to all of these
activities he also serves on the staff
of Sacred Heart of Jesus parish in Grand
Rapids Michigan so now on the topic how
to think clearly about social justice
would you please welcome Reverend Robert
Sirico
what an honor to be associated with this
form with Hillsdale College for whom I
have for which I have a great deal of
respect we share the same great state
although it's easier to get to Grand
Rapids and it is Hillsdale but I know
many of you have made the pilgrimage
there and also to be part of the Center
for the Study of monetary studies and
free enterprise with the Durrell
Foundation these are important issues
that you are examining and for me to be
here is a great pleasure as well as an
honor if the story of Babel in the book
of Genesis has any meaning at all it
certainly has the meaning to teach us
that when words are robbed of their
meaning and employed incautiously in
discourse chaos can result and yet one
need not resort to Encounters of
biblical proportions to see such chaos
at work in our society today in the book
that I recently wrote that you kindly
mentioned I recount a story of when I
was studying in England and I was
studying english language english
english culture english institutions
English literature and I must confess
probed very well into that particular
inquiry of various forms of English
lager and ale and so it came to pass
that many years ago I was introduced to
that British of all British institutions
the pub when I went to the pub with my
friends about seven or eight of us
sitting in a semi-circle we proceeded to
order everyone ordered their own kind of
drink and the waitress without writing
down a single note took note of our
orders proceeded to the bar and came
back with each order and placed it in
front of each person who had ordered it
I was quite taken by the professionalism
of this woman and I remarked on it I
said ma'am you're a real pro and all of
my English friends grew very quiet was
that awkward kind of silence where I
knew I had trod upon something on nice
but was not quite sure what it was so I
turned to my friend next to me I said
what did I just do he said oh you've
just called the young lady a prostitute
and so it comes to pass that George were
not sure observed that American England
are two nations
separated by the same language and now
to our discussion of Babel in our
contemporary use there are a plethora of
words a plethora of words which have
developed new meanings and yet
pronounced the same way as they've
always been pronounced they are employed
in very different ways and for very
different specific political purposes
the topic proposed to me by our host
this evening was the meaning of social
justice how to think about social
justice and this to be truthful is only
one of a veritable litany of words
consider the way in which this list may
fall upon your ears progressive
social market social gospel equality gay
marriage marriage equality fairness
sustainability differently-abled
cooperation investment social commitment
the common good liberal or liberalism
pluralism tolerance diversity and the
list can go on it is enough to drive a
linguist to despair is it not and I must
confess to you that I want my words back
and among the words I want back perhaps
chief of all is the word Madonna
now let us proceed to sort through this
mess and see if we can come to some
sensible comprehension of what we mean
when we talk about social justice and
I'm aware that it is rooted
fundamentally in justice itself now I'm
also aware that there are many
commentators not all of whom are enemies
of sensibility and freedom and the human
person who want to just give up on the
words or the phrase social justice I am
not prepared to abandon it altogether
and I hope to make my case to you now
simply put what we mean by justice is to
say that human beings are entitled to be
treated in accord with what they are due
treatment in a court with dessert you
could put it on a bumper sticker
I suggest that some of the phrases of my
previous litany are really not sensible
concepts but a thing called a plan ISM
that is employing more words than needed
to express oneself a kind of redundancy
now this is not necessarily a bad thing
it can be a benign thing just something
we do for emphasis we talk about tuna
fish do we not or free gift or a true
fact it may be the use of a term for the
sake of emphasis to augment or
underscore something that's important in
the Italian language this occurs for
example when you say I love you
literally to translate I love you into
Italian is to say te amo te amo
now that's the two words are mo being
the first person singular of the
infinitive amore amore to love yo amo te
amo but most often when you say I love
you in Italian other than a kind of
idiomatic phrase which doesn't pertain
here you would say yo te amo well you've
already said I in the first person our
mo but you would say I I love you in
order to emphasis that it is me who
loves you to speak as some do of a
social market is to employ this player
in ISM after all how could a market be
anything other than social the moment
you begin to trade right so if people
wanted to emphasize the social dimension
of commercial activities I doubt any of
us would have any objection if that's
what they meant
we wouldn't be confused we would
understand it like tuna fish but some of
us have a sneaky suspicion that
somewhere out there there is a factory
trying to smuggle in a different
political tilt on the use of our
language something different they want
to add something to the equation that
might not actually be in the equation I
suggest you that suspicion is justified
and that's the problem with social
justice now in preparing for this talk
this evening that I was given I first
got my copy of the Nicomachean ethics
off the shelf Aristotle and then I
pulled down the Secunda second a volume
of the Summa Theologica and of course
right at hand I had Antonio Rose meanies
essay on the
Constitution of justice under social
justice which was written in the 19th
century and as I probe through these
making notes and found these
distinctions on justice and commutative
justice and distributive justice and the
common good and all of these kinds of
rich distinctions it dawned on me that
this was to be a talk after dinner
and so I paused and I thought well this
is a hardy Hillsdale bunch their
intellectual they can take it and then I
thought along the lines of the
Protestant pastor's wife who as her
husband mounted the pulpit folded a note
and handed it to the usher and asked him
to drop it on the pulpit for her many of
you may know this and so he did and
afterwards he confessed to the woman
that I saw what you had written and I
want to tell you how much I admire you
in your marriage you sent your husband a
kiss kis s she said oh no no no that
means keep it short stupid keep it
simple stupid now social I what I hope
to do is just kind of compress this
thing and make it very comprehendible to
all of us justice is rooted in this
intellectual tradition as treatment in
accord with dessert that we are bound to
treat people as they deserve to be
treated but that raises another question
what do people deserve and that raises
yet another question I know I'm getting
a bit too mystic here that's what he
does in the Summa he tasks all these
questions
who is the human person who has the
right to be treated in a particular way
and this is where we come upon the most
obvious thing about human beings if we
ask a few questions about ourselves we
see that the first thing that the human
person is is physiological coal poriyal
physical beings but we know through our
experience by thinking about ourselves
that there is also something more to us
than merely our physicality when we can
love when we can appreciate art when we
listen to music that evokes within us a
sense of our transcendence we realize
that we are transcendent beings as well
as corporeal beings and that is part of
who the human person is the definition
of a human person cannot be observed
from the perspective of a microscope or
chemical analysis we are more than that
and what's more each of us knows that we
are more than that there's another thing
that we are simultaneously in the same
way that we are physical and
transcendent at the same time and in the
same place and that is that we are
individuals there's a sense in which we
are biologically autonomous from the
first moment of our existence in our
mother's wombs we are within our mother
but not physiologically genetically part
of our mother but also at that moment we
are in relationship to our mothers so
this individuality has another aspect to
it we are social beings and the whole of
our lives after our birth is a play
between those two polarities our
individuality and our social component
as is our physicality and our
transcendence these dimensions of who
human beings are need to be understood
if we are going to be able to construct
a society appropriate to the dignity of
the human person if we are going to
speak about human desert if we are going
to speak about justice or social justice
then we have to find the balance by
understanding these various dimensions
and how they play themselves out the
view that the government must be the
complete arbiter the normative role for
all social arbitration should be
invested in the hands of those who own
the monopoly on coercive power that is
the state that that should be the
primary actor in social relationships
which if you listen to the debate last
night a certain someone seems to imbibe
in and he's part of a whole tradition of
this is a relatively new idea and it's
the kind of idea that leads to a great
bit of mischief it leads to economics
and economic misunderstandings now what
does that mean I mean we've recently
heard this discussion about whether
who's built it who built it did I build
it alone but when you take this
anthropology that I've outlined you
understand that the creative person
through individual initiative and
insight into the needs of people in an
economy in a society perceives those
needs and then acts in such a way to
meet those needs that that is a creative
engagement with the material world with
the natural resources bringing their
transcendence to bear their intellect
because our greatest resources ourselves
but we know that we never do it alone
because we've never none of us in this
room have created anything ex nihilo
from nothing we've always done what
we've done in cooperation with others
so it's not a matter of whether it's
individualistic or socialistic it's a
matter of the right understanding of the
relationship between the individual of
the social and the other thing that
human beings have by their nature and
that is the desire and the right to be
free because of our intellectual
capacity because of the fact that human
beings are bound to the material world
by something more than our intuitions
and our instincts because we are bound
to the material world because the
dominant thing that makes man man is our
reason and our intellect that it is our
mind that engages the natural resources
of our world and creates draws out from
those resources things that are valuable
to ourselves and to others what I'm
describing to you philosophically and
morally right now is nothing more than
the economic system we know is free
enterprise and entrepreneurship
now some would say well yes that's all
nice and good coming from a priest but a
real believer of the free market would
be a radical individualist wouldn't
believe in this social dimension well
try Ludwig von Mises on for size in his
book socialism right in the outset of
the book he discusses private property
and he makes what should be to us an
obvious and necessary distinction he
says that there that an owner of course
is one who disposes of an economic good
doesn't that complement beautifully the
citation from earlier from dr. arns and
then he goes further and he says that
there are two kinds of goods that there
is a good that is employed for one's
immediate satisfaction the satisfaction
of a person's wants and that good for
because it's the immediate satisfaction
of a want or desire is consumed is used
up but there's another kind of property
that Mises talks about so let's say you
eat an apple you want an apple you eat
an apple it's used up but the ownership
of an apple or a toothbrush is not what
is under assault today politically and
philosophically no rather it is the
orchard and it is the toothbrush factory
what Marx would call the means of
production it is the ownership of these
things the organization's the
institutions that produce the products
for people's satisfaction the production
of goods that serve the enjoyment
even if only indirectly having these
goods to enjoy them must be shared and
it is shared through the division of
labor so that in a free society there is
a de facto sharing of the kind of
ownership that divides labor and
enriches society so that between the
producer and those for whom labour
produces the consumer there is a bond
there is a relationship there is this
social dimension and this I suggest to
you in history testifies is a far better
more responsible indeed more intelligent
way to accord with human nature to play
upon this knowledge of who human beings
are and all these dimensions I've
already outlined rather than indulging
in what the economists have called the
synoptic delusion the delusion that this
process of productivity and enrichment
for society as a whole can be
orchestrated and planned from the center
of society synoptic meaning one-eyed
delusion that there's a centrally
gathered eye that can orchestrate all of
the productive factors in society and
meet all of the needs because it knows
all of the needs such a synoptic eye
does not exist it is the delusion that
Friedrich Hayek's spoke of in his
masterful though short work the fatal
conceit so you see in this sense the
alternative to free human beings
understood in their rich complexity
acting freely based on their reason on
their apprehension of what the needs are
for themselves their families and the
consumers they seek to serve that the
alternative to that free and nach
system of trade and economic progress
diminishes the intelligence of a society
as a whole
because it prevents more participants in
that society acting upon their knowledge
their subjective understanding of their
condition and the condition of their
neighbors and by inhibiting their
abilities to be brought into that system
of economic trade the entire society
itself is dumbed down and we have
dislocations
we have shortages we have queues we have
starvation we have violence is that the
end of social justice social justice my
friends is not socialist justice
socialist justice is an oxymoron it does
not account for what human beings
deserve because it does not account for
who Yuman beings are and social justice
is no more socialist justice than the
common good is the Communist good the
common good is simply put from the
Catechism is that some that sum total of
social conditions which allows people
either as groups or as individuals to
reach their fulfilment more fully and
more easily that is what the common good
is it's not the ownership of all things
in common which as I've said can dumb
down the society but is the set of
conditions necessary to allow this
wonderful dance between human
individuality and commonality
between the human person as a physical
being and as a transcendent being to
guard to safeguard to institutionalize
the protection of the rights that we
bear in our very nature endowed by our
Creator in one sense justice is the
foremost among the virtues it can indeed
be called the queen of the virtues
because it aims at the rectitude of the
will for its own sake in relation to
others in that sense it may be called
the queen of the virtuous and in another
sense it is the most meager of the
virtues because we know that it that
what is needed for a society that is not
only free is that it must be something
even more than just that a society must
have and know and exhibit charity love
in the last analysis when you and I
stand before the throne of God at that
day of judgment I don't know about you
but I know that I am NOT going to be
demanding justice from Almighty God
I am going to be pleading for mercy
and if our societies do not dispose us
in that manner and how we would be will
we be prepared for that last day
in Michigan where I have lived now for
almost 30 years our community moved into
a house and outside of that house there
was a big tree now you have to know I'm
from Brooklyn New York so I am not
well-acquainted with trees I had seen
one once when I was a child but I I I
think they got it so as I was sitting on
the porch one day looking up at the tree
I saw something curious now this tree
went up higher than the house itself and
I looked up and I saw that on part of
the tree it was completely in blossom
and I'm part of the tree it was dead and
I thought this is very curious what does
this mean and then I discovered the
existence of a profession I knew nothing
about the tree doctor and so I called
the tree doctor who came and who kicked
around at the base of the tree and
crushed some of the dried leaves and
picked it some of the bark and looked at
it and dug underneath and came up to the
porch and he said the the tree is dead I
said how can it be dead it's blossoming
he said ah it's an illusion he said the
SAP has been going through it that's a
big trunk he said and it'll go through
and whatever SAP is in there will give
blossom to some of the tree but every
year it will blossom less and less and
the the danger is that this tree is
weakened and a good Michigan winter can
blow that tree down on your house so we
have to take it down and I have often
thought about that metaphor when I think
about our nation that in many respects
we are living off of a past legacy a
rich legacy that produced a flourishing
bold strong healthy tree
and then these latter days people can
think it's possible to live off the
richness of that former SAP but we must
recognize as I know Hillsdale as a
college as an institution recognizes
that we must tend to the roots once
again we need to go back and look at
what made that tree or this experiment
in human Liberty possible and I suggest
to you that it is the Anthropology that
I've described here that what made this
incredible unique unprecedented
experiment in human liberty and
prosperity possible was the concept of
our founding fathers and of two
millennia of thinking on who the human
person is that that is what made this
possible and that if we do not tend to
those roots the entire tree will come
down I am hopeful that this need not be
the case that organizations like
Hillsdale College and the Acton
Institute and the plethora of other
organizations and movements and
encounters in your homes will ensure
that those roots are nourished and
rediscovered and re articulated so that
we can build an army of people who will
go to the barricades to defend a society
worthy of the human person the free and
the virtuous of society thank you very
much for your attention
thank you
Bellino we now have some time for
questions if you have a question please
wait until the microphone is brought to
you so we all may hear the question
thank you
father Scirocco thank you for your
leadership in the Acton Institute the
Neil Cavuto show in May when your book
came out you made a statement that I
thought was very interesting you said
that it was through the study of
economics that you came back to faith
yes I'd be curious and I'm sure other
people here would be too if you could
explain that thank you
it is curious isn't it of course the the
the the short answer to that question is
to read the book well I would be
negligent as a capitalist not to put a
commercial in for the book really a lot
of what I've said is really that I was
involved with the political left for a
number of years in the early 1970s I was
you name the movement and I was part of
it I was part of the early feminist
movement the early-game movement the
farmworkers movement the boycott of
Gallo wine which I still tried to
boycott when I can I said that once and
found out that the an executive from
Gallo wine was in the audience
we haven't gotten any donations from
them heavily Christian and various other
other movements and a person introduced
me to a friend of his a neighbor of his
and he gave me some books books you'll
know Friedrich Hayek Friedrich Basquiat
Milton Friedman and others I'm sure that
Basquiat spoke at Hillsdale College
right at some point and these these
books have got me thinking about
questions of private property not not
God questions of private property and
the more I probed the question of who is
it that has the right to private
property kind of in the way that I've
done here tonight the more I thought
about human transcendence that's why I'm
so passionate about
economics from an anthropological point
of view because as I looked at that and
saw the human transcendence it was there
that I kind of bumped back into God it's
not a formal proof for the existence of
God I we could talk about that but for
me it was a reencounter it just made
everything fit together it just all hung
together for me and made great sense but
it was of great concern to me that as I
returned to the faith that I had
abandoned as a child the Catholic faith
I came back to a church that had been
turned upside down while I had been gone
and so that there were a lot of the
kinds of people that I was demonstrating
with on the streets of Los Angeles in
the early 1970s now in my seminary in
the 1980s and it was then that I
determined that I wanted to do something
about that first by writing and then by
founding the Acton Institute with Chris
Maron who is here tonight
some 22 years ago
father sir echo I've heard your name and
written your read your works and it's a
real pleasure to hear this evening thank
you I've understand that justice is the
delivery of what one is due who
determines what what is due and does
that work individually or does it work
for groups of people those are very good
questions and in fact I alluded to those
answers here though in a very cryptic
form who determines what one is do I
think there are two dimensions to two
levels to answer that the first is that
the natural law tells us who human
beings are and thus what human being
beings are do by virtue of our intellect
by virtue of our need to be able to
support ourselves our creativity we are
we have of necessity freedom in order to
do that and I think that a government
that is formed whose institutions are
formed based on that natural law tells
us or is rightfully in place to enforce
that dimension of the natural law so who
does it nature tells us and the limited
appropriately limited government is the
guarantor of that secondly your question
is is that accomplished individually or
socially and I would say yes it's both
the the first and and when I had that
citation it really was a citation from
st. Anselm about justice being the queen
of the virtues he speaks about as the
queen of the virtues because it's the
first imperative of the human heart
toward the other acting one toward
another so really in a theological
justice occurs interior ly by our will
by the action of our choices toward
other people but it also can be
institutionalized because it's just
individually it can be institutionalized
socially but the mistake that people
make and that I think a lot of the
discussion today the the ideas behind
the discussion today is that in order
for us to accomplish justice on the
social level it needs to be through the
hands of the government and I think the
government provides or ought to provide
the context as I define the common good
when I had that quotation from the
Catechism the set of circumstances the
opportunities that exist that the
government ensures that ensures that
other people don't violate that but I
think the more normative way in which
social justice is achieved is by the
society which is not to say the state I
think when you collapse the state into
the society you you're on the verge of
totalitarianism that the society acting
through its varied institutions at its
varied levels beginning with the family
extended to the extended family and the
church and other mediating institutions
that all of these together also promote
the kind of justice that is to say what
human beings deserve qualen beings was
there a third dimension to that question
that I missed something there was that
it
can you share with us what you try to do
to influence American society and what
you're trying to do internationally and
what we as individuals and organizations
can do to further that mission the Acton
Institute is an international
organization a great deal of our work is
done here in the United States but we
have several affiliates and colleagues
who are running other kinds of
institutions nationally and
internationally basically somebody asked
me in a form similar to this not very
long ago why we're not more active
politically and my answer to that I was
actually asked why I don't run for
president and my response to that was
that I have a higher calling but they
seemed intent on on getting us involved
politically and I said you know
politicians determine which way the wind
is blowing and what we want to do is
create the wind and so in that sense
what we do is I think what hills dales
does is we helped to form Minds we help
people to think through these questions
and we do that by strategically finding
the best and the brightest people we can
find who are influencers of influencers
we want to form the moral consensus
because our idea is that if people
understand the importance of this thing
in a way that is more than utilitarian
more than the usefulness of the free
society the free society is very useful
it produces lots of wonderful things but
there's something more there's a moral
passion to this and that this is in the
human heart without regard to
nationality ethnicity economic income
level of the whole thing and so what we
do is through a variety of means through
seminars we have a large
yearly seminar that will have almost a
thousand people at this next June the
Acting University in Grand Rapids
through videos and curriculum that are
done in you know really well produced
documentaries and other kinds of
curricula through our use of social
media if you go to for instance our
website Acton org or one of the works
that we're doing right now is called
poverty cure poverty cure is basically
an attempt to gather a consensus among
those who are involved with the
developing world that trade is better
than Aid and that's the the simple
message and we already now have on our
Facebook site you can go to poverty cure
dot org or our Facebook site five five
hundred a half a million likes on our
Facebook page all of these kinds of
means that twittering and all these
other things I have no clue as to what
they're doing but I'm told that it's
very important to do in this day and age
so yes we are international and we use
whatever means available to us that that
can get the word out and help form the
minds of future religious leaders of all
denominations
I just like you to comment on the name
act on where it came from and the
significance well you know this
statement probably this quotation power
tends to corrupt and absolute power
corrupts absolutely and that was stated
by Lord Acton he was in the 19th century
a historian who understood the
importance of religion and liberty
conscience and the free person acting in
accord with their conscience and that's
why he spoke about the importance of
Liberty the other thing he said by the
way was a beautiful quotation that that
Liberty is the delicate fruit of a
mature civilization and so we took the
name Acton as in Lord Acton John Acton
and translated it into an institution
that promotes these these kinds of ideas
of the the importance of religion and
Liberty or you can put it in the way you
have put it here the pursuit the pursuit
of truth and defending Liberty
reverence Rico you began your talk
tonight by talking about words that have
been changed in meaning that he
essentially have been hijacked and about
how you'd like some of the back my
question is it seems to me that there's
some challenges that we face in getting
those words back because after all to
change the words put somebody into the
category of misusing the word but
nevertheless put somebody in the
category of progressive and trying to
get them back put somebody in the
category of reactionary so it seems to
me that we fall into those camps in the
minds of other people when we try to get
the words back and yet we need to get
the words back so how do we get the
words back well I'd say we're the new
progressives I mean you know they stole
them from us where we're liberals we're
true liberals we believe in freedom and
we believe in social justice we believe
in real equality and what that word is
always meant which is not outcome but
common dignity we believe in the common
good as I've already defined it here
these are the things we believe in we
just need to keep using these words
until they decide they're going to
abandon them because they're gonna get a
bad reputation if they keep using so
people always have a hard time pinning
us down you know when I'm on a TV show
or something like that well you're
conservative well it depends on what you
mean by conservative or libertarian but
it depends on what you mean by
libertarian I like liberal I like
progressive why you get them to think
you know you get people out of their
comfort zones and get them to think we
do have time for one more question
in your speech you did allude a little
bit to human nature but you didn't give
an explanation to what it is could you
please elucidate a little bit on that
what is human nature it's always the
last question requires the I think and
really it's kind of a reiteration of
what I did say and that is that human
nature is that commonality that we share
as human beings who are physical and
transcendent an individual and social
simultaneously and that that nature as a
Christian I would say is inscribed in
our hearts by Almighty God even a
believer in the natural law who is not a
believer in God would affirm all of that
that there is a commonality or what we
and there's another word I actually read
this to the litany a solidarity among
human beings because when we see
ourselves when I look and see another
human being I recognize myself in them
and that can happen not just in this
room not just across Nations but that
can happen in history and that
establishes that the reality of human
nature the fact that I can understand a
person alive on this planet 3,000 years
ago or 2,000 years ago that wrote
something I understand their capacity
for love even if I don't understand
their language or their culture I
understand them some essential part of
who they are
so this commonality in a way that I
can't really understand my dog I
anthropology no I I attribute to him
qualities that I have but I don't I see
the commonality I don't attribute them I
recognize them
in other human beings and that that
commonality is rooted in the origin that
we all share as human being so that that
would touch on human nations is
certainly a lot more that could be said
about that but we'd have to begin the
evening anew to do go any further than
that thank you very much for your
attention
god bless you